[Musique]
et louis qui lie à un homme qui pose des
questions sur vous
en matière trouver
big brother observe tout le temps
nicolas
monica disparue à l'été sur une piste
elle avait des preuves irréfutables 2
qui nous avaient piégé quel est le rôle
de la chance
huit de nos amis sont bas
il ya donc quelqu'un quitte à forcer à
donner leur nombre tu ne voudrais pas
savoir qui c'est
on est à la recherche d'une personne
mais si elle n'est pas morte elle doit
être là bas
ce complot est beaucoup plus complexe
que ce que tu pensais tu avais le choix
tu nous as trahis non franchement
souffre la mairie
c'est l'occasion de récupérer et aller
j'en ai fini avec cette vie